ELIZABETH CHOE: Just wrapped
up the end of day six.
Today was the table
read where everyone
showcased their scripts
for the first time.
Table reads are always
so much more awkward then
I would anticipate.
It's just a lot of
dead space and silence.
I'm really feeling the time
crunch with this class now.
The panic seems to
sort of be setting
into the students' mind.
At the end of class, they
were like, our stuff is due
next Thursday, basically.
I do think that their scripts
are in much, much better form
than they were last week.
I guess I wonder if it's
more valuable for them
for me to just give them
the feedback online, which
is what I did for half of them,
versus talk during these group
table reads.
But I also think it's
really important for them
to be able to read the scripts
aloud in front of the class,
and to get some of the
input from their classmates.
I mean, Andrea brought up really
good points to PJ-- or Paul--
at the end.
And that didn't happen when I
was just sending him comments
through Google Docs.
There's a fine line between
constructive criticism
and just doing
the work for them.
I was super tempted
over the weekend
to just say, change this word to
this, sort of be their editor.
And I had to fight
that, because I
think it's more
valuable for them
to sort of discover
that on their own.
But the problem is that
takes so much time,
and it's time that
we don't have.
It's been a challenge
to balance that so far,
and I think it will
continue to be a challenge.
Adjusting assignments
on the fly,
and adjusting lecture
materials on the fly,
and taking stuff out--
a lot of stuff out,
actually-- has been not
the easiest thing to do.
I had a very interesting
discussion with [? Sari ?]
after class about if
this class could really
be feasible in a semester,
in the style of the semester.
I can't really break up a
lecture into 45-minute chunks.
Josh's storyboarding
lecture wouldn't have made
any sense in only 45 minutes.
Maybe it could have, but it
would've been so different.
And it's really
inefficient to just shoot
for 45 minutes at a time.
All in all I feel antsy.
I feel very antsy.
I feel antsy for the students.
It's going to be a
sprint to the end.